how do you make money and no man's sky
when it comes down to it that's all
that's on your mind
you need money or units in order to buy
those hot chips and multi-tools in order
to make life easier in the universe this
is a game that's all about being
efficient without do here's a starter
guide to making money and no man's sky
once you get past the basics in
repairing your ship now what well if you
haven't already the first thing you
should do when you're on a new planet is
scan the wildlife and then upload it to
the Galactic library uploading animal
discoveries typically grants you 2,000
units plants can be downwards to 500 so
scanning and uploading animal
discoveries should be a priority
whenever you land on a new planet
speaking of which whenever you show up
to a new solar system upload your
discovery for five thousand big ones
discover a new planet that's about two
thousand units and here lies another
good habit whenever you enter a new
system the first thing you should do is
land at a space station why
well you're checking out this solar
systems market spend the time and make
know what elements are in high demand
even more specifically the elements or
items March with a star means it's super
hot this system for instance is buying
titanium and zinc for a lot noted now
when you set out to explore in mind
you'll remember to stock up on these two
and don't just land all willy-nilly if
you fly low and slow you'll be able to
spot familiar element deposits that is
once you're familiar with what they all
look like and the other thing about
space stations is the space trucker that
comes and goes
before you leave hit these guys up
because each one of them is different
for the most part they typically buy and
sell items that reflect the system's
market yeah well you're really looking
out for other trade commodity items
these items will vary in price heavily
depending on which truck or you go to
for instance this corvex conversions
cube not very popular to anyone but by
the fifth trader I found someone who
really wanted it this is why you hold on
to trade commodities you can almost
spend all day rolling the die on these
guys
when you exit the station and you're
looking to land on a plant hang on for a
second if you look around you'll notice
curves lines going to and from planets
to the station
these are those traders these are their
trade routes following these lines will
typically pinpoint an abundance of any
given material here for instance I found
an insane amount of copper
if you see multiple lines converging to
one give an area on a planet chances are
they know something you don't
so check it out and if you're unable to
find anything well you can turn to the
dark side and become that space pirate
lastly and probably the quickest way to
flip product is mining in space
specifically near space station clear up
your inventory on your spaceship
you'd be transferring to your EXO
inventory so you can carry more you'll
typically find fami 'im and plutonium in
space so if you're in a system that has
those elements on high demand grind the
hell out of it and there you have it
those are just a few ways I found you
can make money in no man's sky if you
have any tips yourself put them in the
comment section or send them my way on
Twitter and for all of your no man's sky
needs stay tuned to game spot thanks for
watching